well guys I am back from LA and as
promised I'm sharing with you guys the
three interviews that I was very
privileged to conduct I had such a great
time in LA visiting the legends press
junket this is a new TV show that's
coming on TNT on August 13th my first
interview is with Sean Bean and producer
Howard Gordon and just so you know there
were a lot of other interviews going on
around me so there is a little bit of
background noise there's not much I can
do about that I did my best to maintain
some form of professionalism while I was
sitting across from one of my childhood
heroes enjoy the interview the truth
destroy me legends series premiere
August 13 13 and TV I'm sitting here
with Sean Bean and Howard Gordon my
first question for you is as Martin Odum
you get to give a very versatile and
rapidly changing performance is that
something that you have more fun doing
or is that more challenging certainly a
lot of fun and it's very exciting you
know when I first heard about the
prospect of playing Martin Odum I talked
to Howard about it you know eyes is kind
of passion and enthusiasm for you know
for the premise of it was infectious and
you know I was very excited about
playing this character called players
other characters and that was you know
one of the big attractions for me and it
was fun it was also you know I was quite
challenging but fortunately I was here
in Los Angeles and I was in my hotel and
I didn't have any distractions so I got
gave me the chance to it to keep really
focused on what I was doing and I just
had a real lot of fun with it
and you know I was very excited I'm
still very excited about it now just
think about it characters and you know
and actually seeing it because I know
I'm not seeing it all put together yeah
it keeps it really fresh yes you have a
character that you never quite for sure
know what's going on in his head because
the rapidly changing aspect of his
character it makes for as I said as an
actor that's got to be like a juicy role
for you I was yes with the success you
both have already experienced in
television roles
past what about legends particularly
attracted you as a story because your
character obviously is very interesting
but as a story what about that story
particularly for you and and for Sean
made you interested in pursuing it well
it's funny because you said character
but I think character is story and you
know Heraclitus I think I think I don't
quote very many things but I do know
this one which is character is destiny
in a way and and at the center of it is
this character who you know we have a
very durable franchise a guy who goes
undercover and stops bad things from
happening and so we have an engine a
narrative engine that I think is a
reliable one and one that we can sink
our teeth into from episode to episode
but behind it is a character who is a
you know really compelling and again
he's a man of a certain age so I
personally as a writer related to this
character who has some distance behind
him who can look in the rearview mirror
at the road of his life and you know in
this case it's kind of foggy back there
it doesn't quite know where he's been
and it's foggy up front he doesn't know
where he's going I think that that was a
part of it partly attraction for me as
well that you know the kind of that
psychological changes that Martin Odum
and his legends these characters go
through when they're you know and he
pulls himself out there and it really
kind of throws himself into these roles
and these identities but there's also a
very heavy price to pay for that kind of
psychologically and emotionally you know
it's easy to kind of slip into a
character into a legend but it's a lot
more difficult to to get out and and
therefore you so you see that conflict
and you know within his character of
trying to reconcile is his real life or
what he perceives as his real life with
his imaginary life is his legend and
that makes for a very interesting kind
of emotional kind of story
I sent out a few fan question
opportunities and a lot of my viewers
are people who are aspiring directors or
writers or actors and a lot of major
question I got was what do you look for
in a director how do you like to be
directed is there a certain type of
anyone or do you want more to kind of
inspire your own ideas and see what
comes out of it I guess some you come I
mean come to the set and come come on a
set with your idea of how you think
should think should think should be and
it's usually okay
I'm sure if if if you could it kind of
gone in the wrong direction and you
needs a big kind of guidance bit of
advice of it right it's a few
suggestions that that's great so you
know I mean because I'm you know I'm
kind of think I know what I'm going but
I'm very kind of I want to be open to
suggestions and you know someone like
our director Brad - and yes fantastic
you know and just a little little the
suggestions that kind of totally change
your kind of view of the scene and then
and that's in you know ivory whatever
every directors different might gray
film with with the directors we had on
this and they were all very different
and I quite like that you know I you
know I thought wow that helped me change
the characters and get different
sometimes a bit of humor to the
characters which it kind of and I needed
sometimes quite a bit of people are
trying to write TV pilots nowadays
because TV has gotten really
groundbreaking as of late with a lot of
successful shows do you personally have
any advice for people who are trying to
write TV pilots for what really people
are looking for you know uh the you know
the more it more I do this the more I
realize how you know little I know I
mean you know I think the experience
it's not entirely true I mean I would
say right what interesting you have to
have that crate you know you know what's
there's so many reasons to stop a
project to talk yourself out of doing
something so when you find something
that really really intrigues you hold on
to it trust it and and and and and nurse
it because there's a thousand gusts of
wind and rain storms are gonna go on it
but just try to hold on to what excited
you about it and and have patience with
yourself and be hard on yourself is what
I'd say one of the things I noticed
about legends is that there's a really
diverse cast of faces ethnically and
aged and is that something that you
purposefully were trying to do in the
casting process or was that
came together with the right type doing
it I will say Martin Odom's age was
important to me in a way because like I
said before it really was a it was a guy
who had to have had lived a life and had
to have had something to lose which as
he begins to question who he is you know
he has to have those things that he's
gathered in his life so that was
important but then the rest of it and
look I think Ali's character too is
she's also a woman of a certain ages
she's not a 25 year old you know
girls starting out Maggie is but
everybody yeah so everybody is at a
different point in their lives and
asking the same question but from a
different sure point yeah my last
question for you is who inspires you
right now who do you look toward towards
and feel inspiration from um hope
various things you know various things
that you know but that I don't know
pieces of information perhaps on TV or
and media and newspapers magazines books
I don't know if you've got anybody that
it's a special inspiration to me because
you've been a big inspiration to me
personally sir I enjoyed your films ever
since I was a boy seriously well thank
you
yes you're very very haunted and it was
really nice to talk to you thank you
thank you
thanks very much so it's you to keep me
alive
the truth destroy me legends series
premiere Wednesday August 13th and 9:00
on TNT so guys I will also have
interviews coming soon for Ali Larter as
well as Morris Chestnut and David Wilcox
the producer those videos are going to
be coming very soon legends premieres on
TNT August 13th
enjoy the show guys I hope you have a
good time and thanks as always for
watching if you like this you can click
right here and get stubborn eyes
[Music]